[Music]
you've heard all about it Apple's Vision
Pro it's the company's biggest bet yet
on a future beyond the iPhone let's do
[Music]
this yes I got my hands on it and didn't
take it off my face for 24 hours oh
amazing or at least the better part of
hours that feels really nice ever since
Apple announced this headset I've
wondered how is it going to fit in Our
Lives we've already got screens
everywhere what does this $3,500 face
computer do better since I couldn't test
it for long stretches in my real house
can you see my eyes
what know I headed to the Pocono
Mountains and rented this ski cabin
because what are these really if not
super high-tech ski goggles no one's
going to
know so it's noon which is the start of
this
journey what could go
wrong as soon as you put on the headset
you see the real world right
here is a grid of apps the home screen
you just look at what you want to select
then you use your hands to select it
right now I'm looking at settings Now
app store notes photos Safari and to
select one I just
pinch it's really intuitive and to
scroll you just pinch and drag the
coolest thing is how you can place apps
all around you Apple calls this spatial
Computing so I can start writing over
here in a document in front of me I've
got email over here on the left and I've
got music over here on the right I was
all set up to do some real work except
one big problem
this
is
typing yeah it's a struggle for anything
longer than a quick message
thankfully I have never been so happy to
see a keyboard the real game changer for
getting work done adding in a Mac we are
connected yes you get a giant desktop
for your Mac apps and you can run Vision
Pro apps right next to them and you too
can have this for the low low price
of but really I continued to work in the
headset for the next few hours and got a
lot
done next I had to prepare my Persona
remove Apple Vision Pro to begin capture
fix my hair lips can I get a light keep
your arms and shoulders relaxed see when
you video call in the headset it can't
capture your entire face most of the
vision Pro's cameras are pointed outward
so Apple scans your face to create a 3D
standin for you smile with your mouth
closed capture complete it says creating
Persona what is going on with my cheeks
and when I FaceTime people looking like
this it was universally agreed upon I
think you look awful it's like botox
from hell so they did you so dirty
Joe and yes FaceTiming with other people
in Vision Pros is as crazy as you think
oh my
goodness sure there's a lot of
remarkable Tech here but can you really
take me seriously right now Apple says
the Persona feat is in
beta that Persona scan is also used to
show your eyes on the front display so
people know you're looking at them but
it can be hard to see I'm looking right
at you now it would be around this point
where most people would take a break
from this thing I think it was the
combination of FaceTiming and screen
recording but the top of this is very
warm I think it's time to switch into
the the Dual Loop
band feels pretty good I ended up being
happy that Apple didn't strap this
thing's battery to my head I got used to
the hanging pack especially when I put
it in this it's as cool as a Blackberry
holster I had to charge the battery
every 2 to 3 hours so most of the time I
just stayed plugged into the wall but
not for my next activity and here is our
recipe balsamic mushroom and sausage
pasta Crouton is a recipe app for The
Vision Pro so I put the window on one
side of the kitchen and got cooking it
is not recommended to prepare food while
wearing the Apple Vision Pro okay
sure don't worry my producers were
standing by to make sure I was safe
prepping food was really natural
especially I could cut onions all day in
this my eyes do not burn this is amazing
but the absolute best thing so I see the
timer here and now I can move it over
the pasta and now I have a second timer
for six minutes that I'm putting over
the
mushrooms this is just the coolest was
it perfect no you're still looking at
life on a screen in low light I couldn't
read things with smaller print because
of
pixelation is there even pepper coming
out I cannot see it and some stuff just
didn't look like the right color but the
display quality is far better than the
other leading though far more affordable
headset the $500 meta Quest
3 this is pretty much ready that's very
good what should I
watch let's start with some Apple
TV you can create a giant personal home
theater in The Vision Pro because of
Rights I couldn't screen record the 2D
or 3D movies and shows that I watched
and even then seeing it in this video
wouldn't do it justice there's Apple TV
plus Disney plus and Paramount plus but
no Netflix or YouTube apps you have to
watch those through the browser and the
Cinematic 3D virtual reality videos
Apple's offering this is the kind of
stuff that makes me nauseous I do like
one of the virtual reality features turn
the digital crown on the top of the
headset and I am now in a
180° view of
Yos if you're like me and glasses on you
have to get prescription inserts to use
the Vision
Pro I just click in like
that wow crazy browser move over
okay I didn't sleep with it I'm not
insane morning
everyone sounds
delicious Siri what's the weather going
to be today 51 and a chance of rain
perfect skiing conditions let me be
clear no one should ski with these on
Apple's very explicit when you first set
up the headset to only use it in safe
areas but I headed to Camelback anyway
and worked with the mountain to make
sure sure the entire Bunny Hill was
closed off from others he and I only
wore them briefly to record some video
Siri record spatial video nope you got
to press the button hes
on glovs
on here we
go the vision Pro's ability to record
and then watch spatial or 3D images and
videos is pretty great you can record
spatial video with an iPhone 15 Pro but
hands-free recording is one of the best
uses of connected eyewear like meta's
rayb bands so what's it like wearing
these for a day painful but also
insightful The Vision Pro has every
characteristic of a first generation
product it's heavy its battery life
sucks there aren't that many great apps
yet and sometimes it's buggy oh and oof
personas but when you imagine a device
without those constraints you see where
it could be better than holding a phone
to your face Vision Pro is a cooking
computer for right now it gives you a
pretty great way to work and watch
movies is that worth
$3,500 that's between you and your bank
account but in those 24 hours I could
see Apple's Future Vision here a
pixelated yes and a little distorted
glimpse of it that is where are
[Laughter]
you